我真的觉得天变了
真的是天变了
如果说那个是一个时期时代的话
是吧
就是一行行写代码的那种年代
真的你可以通过讲一段话
就让它去生成一个
甚至这个时代软件都是
标准化的
SaaS也是标准化的
但是一直只有10个
20个人小公司
不可能的
它只能用SaaS
那么接下来就是会有一个变化
就是我任何一个小团队
就可以让A7人按照我的需求去
产生软件
就说为什么十倍的效率
目前我们还没有看到
十倍的这个产出
因为组织不是十倍的
因为各种都损耗在
这个组织的结构里面
可能我们大部分人都是农民
因为可能需要这么多重养食
但现在可能只需要少数人
掌握这个技术就可以
然后可能只需要更少的人
去掌握这里面的核心的东西
但这也会需要是顶尖的experts
我认为
他说开车技能可以degrade
但是思考的技能是
如果你没有一步步去做过这些东西
你空泛的reasoning
是不扎实的
每个人都是总督
这里有一个小国家给你管理
这五到十年工作不需要了
大量的人其实生活真的没有意义
好的价值观可能会变得更专
中产阶级坍塌
那么我觉得拯救
这个唯一的方法就是
你把生存底线变高
欢迎回到Indigo Talk
今天我来到一个湾区的朋友家里
第二次去别人家录制
第一次应该是在戴雨生家里
对在Parao Talk
然后我们正好这个话题
应该是差不多两三周以前
两周前
应该两周
两周前这个Sonya
今天我们的嘉宾是Sonya
Hello 大家好
然后要不Sonya你先介绍一下自己
好 大家好
我叫Sonya
然后非常就是之前参加那个Neuro EAPS Conference
我认识的Inderga
然后2024年底
嗯对对对
然后然后就之前之后
当时就已经有录过一起
然后对没乐点
对但是就是当时就聊的挺有趣
当时那一年就是像那个Eliot是吧
我记得有去那个2024的Neuro EAPS
对对
然后当时就聊了很多
然后到现在的话
其实我觉得那个AI发展跟现在
到下为止已经感觉
其实已经翻天覆地了
是的
已经翻天覆地了
然后就没想到
就是又来跟英德狗录一期
对
我们喜欢recap嘛
是吧
我们把之前的东西给
温古尔执行
因为我觉得
这个一年
两年吗
有
没有啊
我们2024年12月份
2024年12月份
到现在才一年
才一年吗
一年零四个月
天哪
我感觉好像已经过了
发生很
太十年了
对
我觉得发现是已经不要太多了
而且我们正好我们上来是说
我们今天想聊一些话题
就是在聊programmer
关于程序
关于AI和编码
对
以及由这个延伸出来的一些编码
大家知道那个Sonia是程序员
对
谢谢硬核程序员出身
我之前前两期也找了硬核工程师
谢谢Interval的这个
你先介绍一下你的背景
对
我的这个career呢比较跳跃
其实我最早第一份工作呢
其实做的是
你刚才把我 shock 到了
对 我本课学的是经济学
然后当时呢
做投行做了一段时间
我就觉得很多东西就应该自动化
然后我当时就是比较幸运
能够回来 Berkeley 这边
读一个 Data Science Program
其实当时呢就 Data Science Program
它已经开始 incorporate 了很多
有 AI 的相关的东西
甚至已经我们当时已经有用 AI
用训练 AI 模型
来做一些各种东西
但是我还没有完全意识到大目
那是可能有四五年前了
OK
就下期必须说在之前
四五年前
不止
可能是
还更早了
对可能不止
然后后来呢
但是我记得已经有碰到
有一次我在conference
碰到一个professor
叫Peter Abil
他很有名的
你也知道
他门下有非常多
做就是那种
Robotic
Humanary Robotics的那种创始人
像包括现在
Physical Intelligence的学生
好像也是他门下
是吧
好像也是他门下出来的
他们都是Berkeley那一派的
当时他的主要的研究课题
就是做家务的机器人
当时我就还有
Ritch out他
就是因为Conference碰到之后
说能不能去到实验室
但后来我就有收到Meta的一个offer
所以我就去了Meta
因为这个好像
这个比较immediate
当时也不知道
而且当时那个我记得非常清楚
你从投行转到
转码
从投行转码OK
对对对
然后当时去到谷歌呢
也是
Meta
因为其实做的也是搜索引擎相关
做的是 marketplace search
还有当时在那个做
instagram的 friends recommendation
后面都是那种搜索技术
其实当时也已经开始
就是因为做search
其实现在大家可能
也可以意识到
就是这个large language model
其实本质上也是搜索一种
是吧
只是现在是通过
natural prompt来做这种search
其实也已经
someone已经用到了行业上
所以但是我觉得
但是我觉得真正让我意识到
AI is something big的时候
其实是后来
我无形中跟朋友
开始办峰会的时候
我才真正的意识到
这个东西是
那是哪一年
那其实是可能快
2020年底
快2023年开始
有这个想法
那不是刚好
ChatGPT出来吗
对 就是ChatGPT
become available to
这个公众
individual的时候
我们才注意到这个事情
就是当时就shock不到
当时这个我们朋友圈子里就说
这个是something like
珍稀奇时代的一个
对整个
对 当时就已经
对对对对生产力的变化
OK对对对
当时呃我记得好像对
OpenA就给这个规估就是一个shock
然后我记得就是参加party
大家会说哦
诶这个东西有多少用啊
就是你可以问他
然后他就一个字一个字跳出来
记得很慢
很慢
当时还在一个VC朋友家聊天
然后呃但是
到现在的话
嗯
就已经是
哦就是such a big thing
对对
OK那你刚才对
刚才讲到那个
要做一份
做这个活动
对
那个是在
那是什么类型的活动
其实几乎都是那种
AI的这种conference
因为当时就是
需要去请嘉宾之后
就开始要研究
AI方面有哪些大牛
然后就恬不知耻地
去请他们
这样子
对
然后就通过这个
因为要知道
谁是这个大牛
然后他们具体做什么
然后
其实就开始
put more attention
其实我觉得attention真的是一个好词
你就开始put more attention into this
这个论文名字取得非常好
对
然后tention就会注意到
他们都在做什么
什么很重要
哪些公司是头部公司开始
所以就开始慢慢慢慢注意到这个东西
也开始有去参加conference
然后认识到Indigo这样子
OK
那你现在已经不在Meta
对不在Meta了
我离开有可能稍后有一年了
对对对
做AI和生物相关的
最近在一些AI Pharmaceutical的一些project上
OK 了解
那我们大概Sony也介绍完了
它之前一直从金融跳到的程序
然后AI 关注这个活动
因为今天这个话题我们最主要的是
想聊一下AI和Programmer
因为说我们从2024年底的那次
Newo的大会之后
其实那个时候
我觉得大家都还聊O1
对
推理
然后推理实计算
然后我们可以
是不是有推理能力
然后可以在多条件选择
然后来做这个强化学习
对
你看看就这么一年的时间
我们从推理实计算
到了Agent
然后到Coding Agent
然后你知道现在的自动体
能够持续地工作
四个小时
五个小时
六个小时
对
这有点
快的
其实我上午还在跟朋友聊
就是
就是基本上每一个季度
性能就翻倍
是的
我也有这种感觉
那么一个
那一个一年下来
那不就是二的四次吗
天啊
十六倍
好吧
基本上后面就指数了
指数了
而且现在
现在还能够就是
它自己的鞋带
然后
自己进化
自己迭代
是
这个速度
现在为什么
安索费
发版本速度这么快
对
因为它整个公司是非常扁平的
它在用AI的结构来看这个
就是它是我觉得
Azorbic这样一家公司
是一种新形态的组织
AI在
因为全员都在用AI
都在用Coding Agent
所以说大家都在分成小组式
让AI快速的把它加速
是的
那么在这个里面
从Meta也住过来
Meta是大机构
也算是大机构
我感觉Meta效率很低
对对对
Sorry没有没有
Meta已经对确实
对
OK是大公司
是大公司
麦上上万元肯定是大公司
那么你从你现在的
你过去这一年多
或者几年嘛
你来看从一个程序员眼中的
来看AI coding的这一个变化
对我真的觉得天变了
真的是天变了
因为呢
你也知道我是转码的
所以我其实就是beam through
如果说那个是一个时期时代的话
是吧
就是一行行写代码的那种年代
然后到现在
我也现在就是写coding的时候
我也是web coding了
就我发现
真的你可以通过讲一段话
就让他去生成一个
甚至整个项目这样子
当然不能说
所有每一行都是高质量的
或者能够比拼得起
就是人类top notch的那些程序员
那些可能写的
还是相对更优美
更精简
更安全
但是我觉得对于
可能绝大部分的
这种coding工作来说
而且甚至对于
最顶尖的程序员来说
我觉得用上这个
也是会提高它的效率
虽然有一些study
说otherwise
但是我觉得overall来说
我觉得整个就是效率就是提升的
虽然里面可能有很多garbage
或什么之类的
slope
或有漏洞
对
这个是
那么你除了这个的变化之外
因为我不知道在Meta
我们可以方便说就可以
Meta用什么模型携带吗
我不知道
因为我在的时候
可能还没有用模型携带
对我在的时候还没有
但是我觉得现在很多
我觉得现在
我听起来朋友们用Cloud Code
还是
就是Enthrofit的
这Cloud Code还是比较多
当然我觉得这个trend
Codex当然也还可以
是吧
Codex也是还可以
那么
我觉得其实来说
这个肯定是
Bip Coding
就是说
最近有个词就很火
就是之前有没有聊到
就是Harmorthing
就是这种
现在这种
其实因为这种
Bip Coding的改变
其实我觉得现在整个
就是去写program的一种方式
肯定会发生一个fundamental改变
就是可能以后好的
就是程序员不再只是说
LimaLine去写call
而是你要设计一个philosophy
是吧
让这个代码怎么去自我的进化
因为现在最近也就是
就是算这个词也不是auto
就是auto
就是让模型自己去进化的
这个概念并不是新的
但是我觉得好像
我记得
我感觉就是现在像Anthopica
还有像Opana提到这个词的这个频率
这首好像是OpenAI写的文章
Agent Harness
或者它有个自动进化的词
我忘了叫Auto什么之类的
就提的越来越多
对
然后
还有模型自我进化
然后但是其实人类需要去做这个Harnessing
Harnessing的Design
但是这个是有点像
我觉得有点像哲学家
你需要设计一个架构
因为你可能就是很难
入白入的去写出来
能做什么不能做什么
是吧
然后更像是一个哲学家
去设计一个理念
然后让Code
他自己去遵守这个理念的情况下去自我进化
这个走下去以后
我觉得
有点像人类变造神
在造每个code product的感觉
对
这个刚才我们聊到了
正好我们就是
我下一个话题怎么聊
因为我刚才在聊你程序员
对
要做一履性工程师
OK
对
这个
有没有从你的这个角度来看
因为我不知道
Meta的履性工程多吗
Meta的女性工程师
特别的才讲
我觉得她overall的话
她是保证到一个
但我觉得
在我当工程师的时候
我觉得女性工程师
还是肯定是比男性工程师少的
少很多吧
对 她可能在其他的role会多一点
对 但是我觉得工程师
reactivity还是
也不是说很难见到
但是reactivity是相比于
男性工程师的角色是少的
而且你看现在SpaceX
好像我听说里面也是
可能还是90%
男性工程师
那我觉得这个话题我想问一下
我就突然想到了
我不知道是不是SpaceX
但是我从那个可能会XI的一些co-founder的比例
XI的co-founder全是男的
对
而且亚裔和印度裔是吧
然后这个里面呢
从女性工程师
因为我觉得
之前说男性工程师
确实他写代码的
这个人多
因为比较枯燥嘛
女性的思维方式不一样
有的可能会creative
有的可能会发散一点
我觉得时间聊天就会发散
好谢谢
我就当做一个优点
对但是把它当优点吧
所以说那么这个发散的时候
在这个里面
你是不是会对这个harness这个工程
有没有什么特殊的一些加分项
或者是有些特别的一些
因为就跟做艺术创作一样
我并不是说
因为做艺术创作
旅选艺术要非常多
对
我觉得后面的
不管这设计这个philosophy
或者做这个
就是说最终质量交付检验的
或者说提出这个想法的时候
我觉得当没有枯燥的编码过程的时候
我觉得男性和女性的这个
这个之前的这个gap就小了
对
我觉得这个东西
不仅仅是从女性
我觉得可能以前的话
就是写代码它有点更像是那种
就很机械的东西是吧
然后你要make sure
每个things set
你不能只
stay在一个很高的
overall的idea
然后你要非常
down to earth
然后
也不是说这个更难了
我觉得好像可能
刚好可能
可能happen to be
更多男性
就是做这个
喜欢做这个
我觉得就是
我觉得所以现在
你会发现顶尖的AI
比如像
像伊莲啊
或者一些像
还有其他的
你会发现
他们其实也会读很多哲学
我以前不太注重哲学
我觉得现在上次我们的活动
看到尹尼亚出场的时候
她已经有AI之神的感觉
对
我们有个朋友
带着一个气场出来
对
当时我记得她有句话
就是她说
public data
data is the goal
然后她说
public data is obsolete
然后她说话
那个感觉有点
她已经是新一代的
AI之神的感觉
对
就是不可
不容忽视的那种感觉
有点
有点怜悯的眼神
看见我们台下的听众们
你们就这样了
我会做下一步的事情
对
就是这种感觉
就是他可能已经foresee
预见到很多东西
然后他只是没有
他可能也讲透了
但是或许我们没有明白吧
OK
刚才讲了
上次讲了
对
那我们说回来
我只绕开了一下
我是旅行工程师这些变化
那我们再说
你刚才在说
AI的Agent Harness
然后呢
这个里面的Philosophy
那么其实实际上
我们有了这一套框架之后
模型和架构
是可以分离来思考的
当然肯定需要一个
很好的编码模型
能力很强
越想越好
但是你给它的这个约束
和你给它的这个
指挥的这个框架
应该也会对你
最终交付的这个成品
会有很大影响
我觉得是
就是相当于
我有一个很好的
发动机之后
到我整体围绕
这个发动机设计的
这个飞机
或者这一个交通工具的
或者这一个火箭
这个周边的系统
对
的结构也很重要
或者说我们再打
用经常用那个
Android Carvassi
比如例子
他总说LM
叫上CPU
就现在他当时还没有
当时做这个图的时候
还没有harness的概念
他现在套上harness概念
就是说我有一套
约束上的东西
我说有内存上下文
对
然后有另外的Io是什么
网络是什么
现在还有很多规则了
有存储文件系统
对
所有东西都在里面
组合成了一个框架
然后它运行
对
这个东西我觉得是
会影响整体的这个
交付的AI鞋代码
从你的角度来看
我觉得会有
对
我觉得会把人类工程师
就是说强行去
一定要拉到更高
高度
你一定at least
是一个更好的
这个系统设计者
是吧
比如说数据库
该是一个什么管理的理念
然后这个
里面的各种
比如说你design的这个product是
是吧
假设你设计的是一个
网红的一个平台吧
是吧
那它应该是一个
什么样子的推荐机制
是吧
你认为什么样的推荐机制是
beneficial的
有益的
什么样的推荐机制是有害的
甚至你都不再去
像我们过往一样
手动去设计很多算法
但是你要设计一个理念
让这个agent嘛
或底下的这个模型AI
自己去设计这些方法的
同时这些方法是要符合你的这个理念的
就是它变成一个
一方面是系统设计师是吧
数据如何
然后算法平台如何
直接如何交互安全漏洞
但另外一方面我觉得
更重要的其实是一个理念的这种设计
然后同时你要怎么去检测这些理念
我觉得会变成一个这样子
是一个更重要的东西
那么就是说
理念怎么定义呢
就比如说什么是好的
其实这个就很难
你认为什么推荐算法就是好的
什么推荐算法就是公平的呢
我今天看到了一个
忘了那个
做音乐的编程大神
那个叫什么名字
之前他跟那个
音乐编程大神
对对对
他跟Antropic
做了一个道德经的一个
真的吗
道德经啊
道德经
他做了一个
重新写的
他提示词写的
然后让Antropic的模型
写了一号
英文版的一个
道德经的解释
然后那个
最近
他不是有一段录音
就挺有名的
就是说
对
我不会写代
但是我知道什么是好代
对
就是这个意思
我觉得刚才
Illigo点到了一个非常重要的
非常非常重要的点
就是我觉得以后
我们人类知道
什么是好的
比我能不能
我自己exactly写出好的
会更重要
就是
但是大家不要小看说
我怎么会不知道
什么是好的
其实你要区分
其实是很难的
因为这不是这些语
如果说你不会写代
你怎么知道什么是好的
对
或者你不知道你写出来的东西
它在不同的情况下
或短期或长期会造成什么样的
cumulative的影响的情况下
你又怎么知道是好的
比如说一个很简单的算法
比如说我以谁最多人点赞
就是为好的
那我可以
如果我让这样子的算法
一直就是作为这个平台的dominant算法的话
那什么样的内容会成为我这个平台的主内容
就是什么样是好的
你怎么样定义好的
这个其实就会变得很难
或者说我不知道就是所有是不是所有的
hallucination 都能够去解决
但是比如说你认为 AI 说的不对
你能不能知道他在说的不对呢
你还有没有能力知道他说的不对
嗯 我觉得我现在好像很困难了
对 有很多地方我得
如果说在我的领域里面
我会比较有直觉感受到他
但是如果说完全不在我的领域里面
我完全看不出来
对
如果一个医疗的
或者说是一个你刚才说里面的生物的
或者说是做那个 pharmacy
就做药的那些东西
那我不在我里
我完全不知道
说的是对的
对比如说他设计一个东西
他说让你吃100毫升
是吧
你知不知道这个是危险
或者说他可能对大门是危险
他可能对某一种人群
是不是就
对大门是安全
对某种人群是极其危险的呢
就是如果他就告诉你这么做
你有没有能力去
意识到这个东西是有危险性
或者说短期来看就OK的
但是长期一晚
可能这个东西是有害的
是吧
假如某种算法
那就是
那比如说刚才
你说到一个很好点
就是你的直觉
直觉可能就是一个
非常复杂的一个模型
然后你就
你现在比如说
英国记得了很多经验
他一看这个东西
他知道
这是好的不不好的
但你这个直觉是怎么了
是因为你
一步一步做这个东西
导致到做出来的
对
那现在的问题
是我刚才的问题就是说
我没有这个
一步一步做的过程
我怎么会有直觉呢
对
我也觉得这个一步
是一个很难的问题
很难的问题
那么这个东西就是说
我不会写代码
想想看
我是曾经写过代码
我写过代码
我也知道写过程型代码
写面向对象的代码
面向模块的代码
然后一层层的这类
搭建这个代码
我知道系统架构是怎么搭建的
这个过程我是为了训练过的
我也学过的
而且你亲手做过
我亲手做过的
你还犯过错误
然后你修正过
我也做过网络
我也做过什么
我们叫frontal and backend
什么我都做过
这些东西我是有经验
我知道一个AI在视频里面
犯的错会有问题
但是说所有东西
我没有做过的情况下
你要去评判
我要去评判它
我怎么评判呢
对
这其实我觉得
会是人类一个非常困难的
就是如果持续的
在每个领域
都保持顶尖的专家
我觉得是会非常重要的东西
就是我们要所有东西
都待会给让AI来去评判
对
那你真的觉得安全吗
这是我先想的一个问题
我觉得我很好奇
其实我也想
后续我会找很多programmer
跟大家聊一下这个话题
然后我自己就觉得
这是一个很危险的
很危险问题
一个问题
就是说当我们没有人经历过
这一步步写这个程序之后
我怎么能够确定
这个里面没有问题
当然还有一种东西
我觉得会这样演化
你看我现在编译器
编成机器代码去执行
我们现在确实不用知道
编译器怎么工作的
我也不用知道
机器代码怎么执行的
但应该还是有人知道的
肯定是有人知道
但是我想知道这个系统的运行起来
就不需要知道的话
所以我觉得我们现在应该是从
我们叫做可能面向一个文件来编成
面向这个就是你要写一行行编译文件
比如说Python你要写.py文件
然后如果说你要TypeScript
你要写一个.js文件
或者说.cpp
然后这样的文件
你都是要交付文件
然后编译继续做执行
但是现在我们会变成
我不用面向这个
我面向一个agent
我面向一个目标
我说我需要把这个功能完成
或者我面向一个model
你帮我把这个model做了
但是这个model之间
我很难组合它一下
就是我从一个抽象程式上升到
一个更高维的抽象程式上去
我觉得可能是这样子
然后下面我就不用管了
我根本不用管type script
里面的过程是怎么组
是的
我不需要了
但是我得知道
这个系统是怎么组合起来的
对
我觉得可能就有点
就是我随便的一个猜想
我觉得会不会就像
以前可能我们大部分人都是农民
因为可能需要这么多的重量
但现在可能只需要少数人
掌握这个技术就可以
然后到现在可能
没有人掌握这个技术
应该还是有人掌握这个技术吧
然后
现在肯定是有的
龙面肯定是有的
对对
然后可能会压缩到每个领域
可能只需要更少的人
去掌握这里面的核心的东西
但这些人会需要是顶尖的experts
我认为
对
因为我觉得还是要
需要有人类知道一些know how的
然后其他大部分
我觉得就去用就好了
那我真的学
你是转码啊
对
我没有的意思
大家会转码
肯定说这个收入高
我才转码
也不是因为找不到别的工作
对
那么就很多人
我来说写的真的是爱好
我就想研究
这个过程是怎么写出来的
那就有人类
有一部分人类
喜欢干这件事情
然后他会成为这部分专家
对
因为没有人要求你这样干
效率会更高
没有的
因为我AI做的效率会更高
是的
但之后有一部分
很执着的人类
会干这个事情
对
你说的太对了
要考古一样
对
很多部分我可能只会在agent层面上去
面向对象编程
面向文件编程
面向agent编程
就会成
我感觉会成为这样的一个结构
是
我非常同意
英德国说的话
我觉得可能就是
刚才你说有部分很小
部分可能对某个领域真心的执着的人
可能以前很多人做很多行业是说
卫生系所迫
但可能以后是
可能就是说
因为这个
我就是OK
可能我做这个
还是没有什么钱
也没有什么
直接回报
甚至我的效率
还没有AI高
但因为我还是很喜欢
然后我就不停地研究
那么可能
我就能
maybe maintain
成为那个领域的专家
但可能绝大部分
并不需要再被迫
并不需要
对
并不需要一定地
去做这个事情
那么可能
可能其他人类
更需要的是一种
creativity啊
新的想法
对
这是我们后面
很聊的问题
就是说
因为很多东西
就是我们的执行
越来越抽象
往上层走
对
现在面向agent变成
那我记得面向
面向什么
面向最终交互
或者面向一个idea变成
对
我可能真的只用提示
他为一个idea
他就帮我实现了
因为他也很聪明的
对
那么这个里面呢
我觉得
我刚才在聊了
Harness的驾驭
实际上我觉得
很多的工作
我要
如果说就把AI
当成一个很好的助手
对
他能很好做出
你想要的东西
但是有一个gap在这里
就是说
我得把我的想法
我想要的具体的
和别的不一样的想法
告诉这个AI
让他帮我实现出来
因为现在AI里
他做一个很经典的东西
他肯定是按照他的这个
所有的训练信息里面
给他一个
因为自回归模型
Transformer
除非是我们有新的机构
变化了
大家一定都是一个
非常common的东西
那么我觉得
接下来的博弈就在于
我就会让他更像
我想要的东西
对
就是可能以后
不同会变得更重要
Creativity 会变得更重
我们刚才之前还来到
最近有一个
硅谷很有名的一个
抗衰专家叫 Brian Johnson
他最近的一个采访里面
他就提到
他在嗑药
他在吃一种
好像级别比普通迷幻药
还要高好几倍的那种迷幻药
然后他就说
他 unlock 了 something
然后他说
他说或许人类以后
需要在这个创造力和一些感知体验上
就比现在有更大的这种突破
才能去创造新的有意思的东西
因为可能执行已经变得不这么重要
但是你的idea就变得很壮
就是你跟别人idea有什么不一样
你的感知跟别人有什么不一样
这个可能会变得很重要
对
但是这个
它是在医生的这个辅助下的
对 让我盖上了一个点
强化主观体验
因为有限是这个是为了抑郁要获什么其他
对 我说强化
很多药物可以强化你的主观体验
对
因为你没法通过这个药物来换新
为什么很多创作者是原来一点
对 还有运动
运动员也会
运动员也会不行
但是比赛也不行
对
但是创作的过程中是可以的
那么我觉得主观体验
在AI增强里的其他的流程过程
就是写代码之后
主观体验会更加重要
对
做代码或者做产品
更像是艺术创作了
对 更像艺术创作
那我感觉那你交付给其他人那种感觉又不一样了
因为这个就是说
我加上我的AI做的东西逼你
哪个比方说逼你好
逼你好
对 或主观的比我好
对
就是这样
不然现在这个有一个
我们正好可以跳到另外一个话题
就是我可以把后面的话题提前说一下
我们现在的软件
这个时代的软件都是
标准化的
Yes 标准化的
SARS也是标准化的
那是因为很多
没法请很好的团队去定制化我的需求
每个企业每个人都有自己的不一样的需求
当然有很多是一样的
这个可能SOP是一样
但是呢
你涉及到一个组织
大的组织
META是可能能定制自己所有流程的
对很多东西都是internal tools
但是一个只有10个20个人小公司
不可能的
不可能
它只能用SARS标准化
那么接下来就是会有一个变化
就是我任何一个小团队
就可以让Edgeant按照我的需求去产生软件
对对对
这是一个最近
在投资界
我觉得类似于发现
我觉得是一个Avalanche
雪峰的一个概念
就是SaaS软件的
这个存户空间在哪里
就是这种标准化的SaaS的公司
它到底存户空间在哪
因为以后
是不是MJKPATI也有提到过
他说以后的东西就是
谁要谁写
是吧
对的
对我需要的工具
我告诉这个
LarginLimper Model
让它写
是吧
或者可能不是Language Model
就大模型去写
然后写完用完我就集气
用完集气是吧
甚至可以集气也可以继续用
嗯也可以继续用
对你可以继续用
但是意思是你可以完全定制化你想要的
我不再需要stick to
你要你就是以前说
SaaS固定的页面
你必须要这样这样用
那样子的output不需要了
但是这个我就会增加一些使用难度
嗯你说以前还是现在
现在如果是到这儿我的需求定制
可能就产生不了一些
training一些新的人来使用这个系统
那可能就不需要了
所以说这个东西会产生很多变化
就是说
当然我想乐观的
可能就不需要再确定的人用了
这也是另外一个
最近很活话题
就是说可能以后的工具
并不是给我们人类去用
现在不是已经2026年
第一月份已经开始
从OpenCloud开始
我们都面向agent开发
我给了各种工具
让agent才用这种工具
是的
包括以后网页的浏览
现在就是也是在
可能以后也是
所以网站会双版本
一个叫markdown版本
一个叫webview版本
对对
就是给agent去看的
因为我们人类看的东西
跟他看的
就是格式可能不太一样
对
就我们的efficiency
效率太低了
是需要这个可能
那我正好我这样做的
我自己一做交易吧
你先做投行
作为一些投行
对不算交易
我在做投资的
我可以给
我现在就是让AI分成几个角色
有的AI负责marketing观察
情绪
有一个AI负责trading
他知道每一只股票应该
何时是买入点何时是买出点
有一个AI就负责
去get这个公司所有的新闻
还有一个AI会负责评估
仓位平衡
我弄了四个
可以
但是呢我是这样子
我没有去做一个
我是这样
我没有让他去做一个
做成固定的程序
我就让他去完成这个任务
让他把每一次执行
结果以及结果写成MAC当文件
然后其他的H
你就可以看这个MAC当文件
你市场情绪
今天开盘会结束之后
你读了这个市场情绪
你就写出来
你就今天市场情绪怎么样
今天那个恐慌指数
今天的那个
美国发的
Fed发的什么信息
宏观 微观的
他都写出来
写个小笔记
然后另外一个agent
做交易的时候
也可以看这笔记
对
因为你还可以搞个agent
是criticize
你现在的agent
做的事情
对对对
然后这都是中间
其实我看不看无所谓
最终我还弄一个功能
我就弄一个agent干嘛呢
你把这所有markdown
我渲染什么
也给我看
对
present给老板的这个功能
就是以前可能那个
需要一个
单独给Anders
做的给老板汇报的工程
就是现在
也让一个agent就
对
然后我就
我可以不用关心
他们的中间的
马克弹文件什么的
当然我可能没找到
更好的agent通讯方法
但是我觉得
让他们用文本的通讯
就很好了
是
对吧
这是我的想法
对
就是以后可能
就是你看
以前是要很有情人才能
是吧
有一个固定的团队
不同的角色去做这些
再一个人
他就能够调动很多agent
就是每个人
都可以变成一个资本家了
就会这样子
老板
每个资本
对
所以我早上跟朋友聊
就是我们未来人
就两种
就是人均创始人
人均boss
还有人均资本家
就是剩下两种人
然后剩下的没有什么工作
你也可以做的
然后剩下你就relax
但是人类就属于在投票
就是因为可能每个人
都会有点
token或钱
是吧
就是ok
我觉得你的idea好
是吧
我就把token
撒向你的项目之类的
或者我就把时间
或者我的attention
span在你创作的项目上
对
attention很重要
就是说我接下来还是
其实我有一个想法
我觉得这个社交网络更重要了
在我有充足的时间的时候
我们所有人都创造这些
垃圾
但是人就是喜欢消费
别人的贪心
或者我喜欢获取别人的贪心
其实现在网络上很多
大家大部分时间消费东西也是垃圾
但是它可以给国家的快感
对
80%应该是属于垃圾
然后20%是可能
那可能90%都是垃圾
好啊 比例也 underestimate 了
嗯嗯嗯嗯
是的 就是我把话插开一点啊
所以说在在这个
嗯
我刚才说的是
把文件当中介 agent 的通讯
对
这就是成了一种新的方法
我们面向 agent 来做开发
是的
这是一个很大的变化
在整个呃
在 web coding 之后
变成 agent engineering
或者 agent harness 之后
对
这一个很大的变化
那我们之前提到了这里面
我们上一次正好提到
我想跟你深入交流一下
就是关于这个
其实这个东西
所有的东西回归到
我觉得有一个
我建议现在大家所有人
去用agent
或者想做agent harness
这个人
特别在做AI
想驱动AI编码的人
大家重新回顾一下
Unix系统
Unix哲学
OK
就是我觉得Unix
是一个以文件为核心的一个系统
Everything is file
我不知道你从你的角度来看
我还真是不知道
这个我还得向你请教一下
但是听起来是一个
everything is file 是吧
对 everything is file
在Utik系统里面
everything is file
然后它就是
因为它上面
如果说你能用文本代码
文本来存储文件
那就优先用文本
不要用而禁制
然后所有网络协议也是一样的
如果优先用文本
那就不要用而禁制
然后另外一个
所有的in and out
其实都是在写文件
读文件
那么其实你现在看
为什么open cloud那么流行
它的这个工作那么有效
他就跟你创造了一个workspace
然后里面有你的memory
有你的那个soul
是的
灵魂
那都是具文件的
是的
一个agent去这个目录里面看
他就能看到你
哦
我应该用什么风格和风格和方式
来执行你要做的事情
是的
他一读文件就知道了
现在agent读文件特别快
是的
一个目录给他就好
那这个东西就回过了unix哲学上面去
所以我觉得这一点
只是说这个时代
我觉得agent的OS
更像是一个升级版的
一个Unix OS
我觉得是
就是everything变成可以document化
对
everything就是可以文件化
就是
这是
以前可能没有
就是很多数据是
unstructured
是吧
以前可能没有办法去这么大量的处理
unstructured的数据
但现在它其实可以甚至从里面去获取到你的风格
是吧
你常规处理的SOP流程
或甚至
rare case
是吧
极端的一些例子
它可能都能够在你以前处理的这文件中
已经找到
已经学习到这些东西
之前用Cursor的时候
它不是有一个Rules文件吗
你用着用着
你说这个东西不对
然后它记下来
是的
然后你在
其实后来Cloud也学它了
是的
就有一个Cloud文件
然后你可以把很多东西记下来
然后将它思维摸入
就感觉一个
电脑上的一个folder
就好像是一代APP一样
对
然后agent加上folder
它就能够干活了
是的
所以那个Skills也很火
其实就是包括比如说
是吧
你是一个人
然后你可能长成一些技能
可能就是已经都设置为各种skills
然后它就去调用
然后包括你说到这种
可能文件风格
然后或者你常规
你对所有事物的一个整体的theory
是吧
一个规则
我觉得现在就是
其实都是可以
其实也已经都是这样子做的
所以就是这些东西
都可以从文件里面去extract出来之后
这又提到最近文很火
好像就是大家在吵架的概念
就是说公司其实现在把你的
公司什么
就公司很多时候就是在
现在就是在收集你的这些skills啊
然后风格啊
就是someone就可以复制你
什么意思
我在留着场合理解
公司在收集风格
不是工程师
就是公司
工程师啊
公司
对
比如他在看你平常是吧
怎么
这可能是一个有点ambiguous的话
也就是说公司在看你怎么跟AI interact
然后去学习你
就复制可以复制你
我知道意思
就是你把我所有人爱聊天的东西都录下来
对对对
因为可能你跟我处理同一个case
我们是不同方法
但可能你处理的特别优
是吧
对
那我就让AI学习你
是吧
对这个方法
现在不是
我觉得接下来招工程师
一个这样招了
你不用考他这些编程技巧
对吗
你考他怎么和AI聊天的
对
这个记录给我看一眼
我也知道你是什么风格的
对或许这样
对对对
但我觉得就是
可能最顶级的人
还是要考一下怎么写
因为刚刚我们说到
那个审查员也是很重要
审查员也是很重要
可能大部分的
就是看你怎么跟AI对话就好
但是我觉得少部分的
这种在每个领域的审查员
是非常重要的
对对对
了解
对
那我们刚才就
我刚才说到的
Utics哲学
说everything is file
对
再说回来
然后呢
我说现在的agent OS
是基于文件的
对
还有一点
这个OS还有一个确定
就是Utics哲学
还有一点就是说
确定性优先
能够用代码解决的
我就用代码解决
我不会再让AI每次
因为这个任务
再去重复的
去生成一次代码
我就会把这个东西
工程记下来
把你解决
除非是解决不了问题了
我再去生成一次
你这样子整体的
这个效率会很高
你说的就非常像skills
为什么他们现在
写不同的skills
markdown呢
就是因为
这样我不用
不断的去写一个
具体的东西
比如说我要完成
这个任务
我设计到五个skills
然后可能这个任务
都是ABCDE五个Skills
然后那边是BCDEF
然后那有interact的这种Skills
我只要掉那个Skills就可以了
对 其实也是类似的
我觉得类似的概念
这是一个很大的世界的一个变化
整个 这其实就带到
我觉得另外有一个最近概念也是挺火
我也挺想提到
就是最近很多VC在问一个话
就是说为什么十倍的效率
目前我们还没有看到十倍的这个产出
对 为什么
是吧 为什么呢
因为组织
因为组织不是十倍的
你沟通都损耗在这个组织的结构里面去了
这个我觉得是
我自己理解的是最大的原因
因为个人可以把效率提成十倍
但是你把这些所有人
阻塞在一块去的时候
他就是最慢的那个人
对 那个人是不是一个bottleneck
那可以把他踩掉
所以说很多公司就是现在在要挟大家
我给你这么多token
你用不好你就走人
但是也有人用的呀
那不是用出大问题了吗
最近前段时间Cloud
Authrafic
对把自己代码原来码公开
对对对
我估计那行也是AI写的吧
但是
有可
是吧
而且有这么多
每次AI都产这么多code
你要是一行review
你也review不完啊
这也是最近亚马逊的
他们要求
就是虽然code产生很多
但他们审批的很慢
就是因为
他们好像出了几次大的
那种代码事故
就是那种
然后导致就是
网站停摆
然后巨大的损失
所以他们要求
就是人类还是要去审核AI产生的code
但我觉得有可能
这只是一个阶段性的问题
因为我觉得
要是真的看我们人脑去审核所有东西
那太慢了
平均太大了
我觉得会又变成一个新的包头带
对 我觉得
我觉得这个你刚才说到
为什么没有Space的公司
因为
现在
组织结构的这个
组织的高通层级都是人搭建的
是的
从罗马军团
军团的一级
二级三级下来
然后现在我们把它制度化了
很组织这样走的
这个里面每一级指定
往下船都会损耗
而且你还要下一层的人prove吧
就不说一层
就是在这个节点的人
还要prove是吧
对
然后呢
还有一个核心问题
就是指挥层
你只能把中间
每一层都抽象之后
你必须得通过中间层
才能够把下面
传达下去
对
一个指挥层
没有那么大带宽
去直接指挥前面每一个
对
但是现在的变化来了
agent可以直接穿透
直接回到前面每一个
因为他们就是一个swarm
它可以很快速地协调调配
前面你看你用cloud code的时候
它很快
但是你可以设置这个数字
其中六个agent
其中十个agent
甚至一百个agent可以在swarm
都行
只是说你的这个torten消耗
速度太快了
对 钱够不够
对 只是钱够不够的问题
不是说其他的问题
不是说算力模型有什么能力问题
那么组织变化就会变成
如果说
我肯定会有一个
如果你是老板
你有个最大的目标
然后下面就直接是agent
对
他分配所有的纸的agent
帮你把任务安排好
对
然后代码软件
所有的数字端的东西
全部都可以给AI处理完
就是整个更扁平化
更扁平化
以前是可能五六层
现在可能就两三层
两层就够了
对
然后人在那边做什么呢
如果人不用写代码了
人不用做设计了
人不用搞任何文档了
对
那在公司里面人做什么呢
你可能还是会有一个人
负责几个板块
我认为就是在
at least在现阶段
我觉得就算作为过渡阶段
我看到那个Jack Twossey写的
那个他们发一篇文章
Blog的他裁员嘛
他给裁员找了好的借口
他找了一个好理由而已
不是
但之前就人糟多了
对
最近那个Mark Anderson
那个Anderson那个创始人
他也说现在很多公司号称是
用AI作为一个借口去裁员
对
现在是借口
但过来年就不是借口了
对
过了年其实不会是一个借口
就是真实存在的
那么就是说
这个里面人做什么
人在这里面就转到边缘了
边缘是什么
就是AI再怎么好
它在现实世界中
它没有experience
没有接触
所以人更多的去做情绪关怀
做沟通
大部分的人
大部分人都是干这些事情
或者说你需要一个人
去体验一个什么
去交代
传达一个什么
需要人做一些接触的
那就是人都在干这种事情
是给AI跑腿
然后把所有的数据收获
通过一个模型传给AI
AI分析处理
就是相当于
我们的小老的发挥的作用
就叫驾驶来
大老就慢慢地被
被AI给替代了
所以我觉得
这次最近我一个很好的朋友
他说就是有
就是因为我们最近用驾驶
自动驾驶用多之后就发现
慢慢地我们开车技能也
就是degrade
我就是这样子的
对
然后呢
然后我个朋友就说
他说
开车技能可以degrade
但是思考的技能是不能degrade
但是就回到你刚才说一个很重要问题
但如果你没有一步步去做过这些东西
你空泛的 reasoning是不扎实的
你很容易就会被mislead
是吧
误导或者被错误引导
就这个其实会变得很可怕
但如果以后
就说我们有token
我们 retention可以去mult
但如果我一个没有对的这个判断能力的话
我问出来的东西到底是什么
其实这个会变得很可怕
所以我觉得未来世界可能会变两个极端
一个就是我们还是需要大量
我们会需要有更多的顶尖expert
因为这些人才能去跟这个模型
去做alignment
做这个是吧
审核
但是其实其他的人呢
就像你说的可能更多的这个attention
放在生活和关怀上
但其实我觉得会上面的人也是会稀缺
就是其实我们需要更多的人类的顶尖专家
但是我发现人是不能够被逼迫的
就是我不能逼你成为一个顶尖的专家
是吧
比如我
现在都不好逼了
这有点像是
假如我们人类活在真的一个更富裕的世界
就每个人都像一个富二代一样
那富二代是很难逼的
你可以现在观察一下
现在富二代在干什么
对
最近好像很多人说富二代
以后你想人人都是富二代的
对我听说老Skattles的富二代
很多人就是会
那个就是寻找一些刺激的
寻找意义
刺激的东西
对
其实这个会变得蛮可怕的
变得蛮可怕
可怕的
我觉得会可怕的
就是
对
如果那些
我觉得会有点可怕
对
就是说好的价值观
可能会变得更壮
对
但没办法
我觉得如果
就这个话题
你跟我之前所有节目都聊过
是吗
对 聊了很多次
这个意义是什么
就是说你现在一下子
我们从工作里面释放出来了
人是没有意义
因为你过去两三百年
工业革命之后
我们就是为了这种
劳动工作
突然一下这五到十年
工作不需要了
大量的人其实生活
真的没有意义了
当然可能意义要重新建立
但建立的过程非常漫长
就是更早以前
我们就是生存嘛 是吧
打猎 种田
就是活下来
后来就是
有农业生产和工业生产
就回来了
对对对
反正这两个都不要了
就是我们智力被替代了之后
就是除非我们的脑
能够开发得更
那个什么什么
对
在这个问题
这个话题很难回答
就很难回答了
对
是的
那我们说回来一点点
说回来一点点
就是我们说软件和程序员
那就是程序员决策转变
什么
或者软件
会怎么演变
我觉得可能就是
就回到那个harnessing rule
就是我觉得
我觉得更多的程序员
然后就是程序员
他可能就是去设计整个philosophy
他变成一个这种
一个东西的这种
实用的理念的设计师
对
就好像
我回到刚才举的那个例子
就是说
我们可能还是会有社交平台
是吧
那这个算法的这个philosophy
应该是什么
是吧
就是我觉得可能
这些才会变成
就是不再是传统的工程师
是line by line写代码
而是说我们认为什么要是好的算法
其实就是这个taste
这又有人提过
就是taste
还有刚才你说的这种judgment
会比这个本身execute更重要
就是说我要做一个这个推荐品牌
那什么样是好的算法
什么样会产生好的influence
现在都为商业最大化呢
对就是所以那个目标是什么
就是这个metrics
就我们做工人生最喜欢讨论
就是说你的metrics是什么
或者你训练一个模型的时候
你的metrics是什么
就是
那我觉得好
以后的工程师
他的这个工作会变成说
OK我们这个目标是这样子
那么这个就是
我们怎么定义这个metrics
是吧
它可能不是单一维度的
然后我们现在的这些东西
就设出来这个理念
或者说一些算法
或者说如果还有算法的话
是否能够真的去满足
我想要的这个metrics
因为你知道一旦有metrics
然后很容易发生扭曲
然后就是说
那我们现在设计的这种系统
是否真的能够
truly serve
我们这个purpose
我觉得会变成
这样子才是这个
所以什么
就是这个
别人说
好像说
安华比的这个东西
这个带
马罗星好
就是因为
他的那个philosophy
显得好
对
有人这么说
我不知道是不是真的假的
或者训练书记挑得好
对
他很会整数据
他还有
第一个是
他目标清晰
他知道干嘛
对
他不会说
open eye就有点跑乱了
东想做下
西想做下
他放弃了好多
他放弃了生徒
放下来做视频
放下来做所有的
他只一心做代码agent
当然他本身的
Athropec的这个模型的语言表达
能力一直都是不错的
他最接近自然人类的这种表达
就说人化嘛
他说人化的模型
然后后面他又强化了代码
但是代码会和做语言表达
是同样的
代码好所以语言也好
然后还有一个就是
agent训练了多步
完成工作
这个东西确实是
做得最好的
是
所以除了
就是这些工程做得好之后
我认为以后的工程师
就如果还称之为工程师
就是他如果定规则
制定规则
我觉得会比写代码更重要
就设计这个理念
制定这个规则
会比这个
就每个人都会变成一个治理者
比如说你负责这个软件
你可能是这个软件的治理者
就你的governance是什么
是吧
你会把这个governance
你是一个推进性
你这里的生态
你这个治理的怎么样
我觉得就是你会变成
可能一个平台
只需要一个空城市了
是吧
你治理的如何
就是它是变成一个更
每个人都总督
对
这里有一个小国家
给你管理
应该怎么搞
因为有一些平台
可能会变得很extreme
是吧
就是我就是搞不理
或者我就是搞很extreme的语言
就在这爽
因为有一些平台
是可能就是很温暖
很sourness
很encouraging
就是我觉得会变成
就是变成是一个治理者
而不是就是
核心不再是line by line的鞋代码
以前可能最牛的人是说
这个code没有人能解决
OK
他能解决
这是最牛的
但可能以后更好的程序员
最好顶尖程序员是
他的这个
他是一个治理者
我觉得会是变成这样子
对
这个确实需要很多转变
因为现在的
那一位程序员的工作
这个理念
不是
程序员的数量会减少
因为通常来说
不需要那么多治理者
因为你大量的
除非说我觉得这样的
首先程序员的工作会减少
这个工种会减少
但是随着这个发展
随着我们创造东西的速度越来越快
多样化
比如说媒体创造或其他创造
但是对于这个
治理的这个需求又变多了
会的
然后那个时候
从此这个人有会变多
他会先减少
然后再变多
你说这个趋势很对
我觉得会是这样子
就好像
就减少的是传统意义上的程序
因为它实在没事情可做了
没事情可做了
但现在还没到这个程度
我觉得还远远不到这个
就现在可能只是说
没有 我觉得明年就差不多了
我觉得现在可能很多
王城市他是集中在这种
比较top-notch的这种科技公司里面
可能他会变外流到其他的中小型企业
因为以前中小型企业
他找不到好的
找不到程序
对
找不到好的
然后可能会外流
就是溢出到其他行业
我觉得会是这样子
然后但是可能不再有这么多人
涌入这个行业
但是就像你说的
那随时就是可能生态越来越多
就是百花其放的时候
又有这种
无论是程序员还是治理者
那就会
APP 治理者又会又越来越多
但是可能不再是传统的
所谓的程序员
对 是的
所以我们叫 Builder
对 Builder
你叫 Builder
就是首先他会因为
会因为 AI 代表代表人力变强
他变成治理者
那么在很多大公司里面
他之前要很多人暴力去写代码的
工作就不需要了
对
但是呢
这个普惠到所有的公司
任何一家小业务公司
它都有能力用软件给你赴能了
对
那么它可能又要在市场上
去重新找这些有这种
变成能力的人
但是它可能发不了
那么高的薪水给它
对
可能会变成一个更普通的工种
但是呢
我觉得还有一点就是
雇用关系都会变化
雇用关系会变化
我一个小公司
你可能只用花了一百
百分之二十的时间
去给这个公司服务
另外一个百分之二十的时间
给另外一个公司服务
对
都变成这样的
就是我叫contract
对
方式
就是虽然说你给一个公司服务
公司你赚的钱很少
但是你给五家公司服务
你可能你的能力好
那你也能够合理之前比较大厂
干的赚的钱还多
有可能
但是会比较累的
对
我觉得你说的很多
可能我觉得会有一部分人会变得更累
嗯
我现在变得很累了
因为你可能有很多AI任务
反馈给你等着你去
对
等我做
你做下一步你审核
然后做下一步 decision
其实你
就是我觉得会有一部分人变得更累
然后其他一部分人会变得更闲
因为不会每个人都是一个治理者吧
是的
不需要
不需要那么多治理者
对
但是呢
你随着业务总的变多
就是老板会变多
老板会变多
因为大家业务会被拆小
所以未来我们就说
如果说
我也我有一个结论
你可以反馈一下
我们就聊最后一个话题
我们就差不多
你快一个小时
对
我觉得任何一个公司
都会变成软件公司
任何一个业务都变成软件公司
然后呢
在这个里面呢
只会存在
一人或者几个人的小公司
和巨型公司
我非常同意这个结论
中间公司没有了
所以这个对于很多投资
和大家想做事情来
我觉得这个很现实
那这样是一个好事还是坏事
这是
这没有中间形态了
就跟现在社会一样
社会就是中间中产阶级坍塌嘛
对对对
那么我觉得拯救这个时候唯一的方法就是
你把生存底线变高
对
UBI什么房子底线
大家有一定的收入
基础收入之后
然后在这个上面去实现价值
对对
不然那这个社会就坍塌掉
坍塌
嗯
对对
是的
那你觉得好还是不好
不可避免啊
AI都这样出现了
我觉得唯一能够改变的
可能会有立法
但立法也改变不了趋势
对
即使有法律
能够限制某些行业
不让人家积极地去
adopt进去
但是你改变不了这个结果
因为它就是效率高
就会进去
对
我一直有个可能
就是可能不是很realistic的想法
那我想上次
我不是跟你见面
我就说那宇宙这么大
那咱们可以每个人
assign一个外空
外太空的项目呀
你觉得这个可以吗
那是给我们的
外太空的探索能力变强才行
现在不行啊
现在太难了
对
所以说我觉得
未来
我觉得有个意义
人类的意义危机
我觉得Elon Musk
帮他解决个危机
你还是往新神大海探索
才能解决我们意义危机
对
你要发现宇宙才行
不然就
我们就困在这个星球上
然后导致意义空虚
没有下一代
慢慢慢慢
就真的就没有了
如果说你都困在这个星球上面
随着这个自然体越来越厉害
你能干得越来越少
消费也会减少
就一块坍塌了
嗯
你不去开阔新的疆界
就全部坍塌掉了
嗯
对对
对吧
我们最后把这个话题升得很高吧
哦
升得很高了
好
外太空线值得探索啊
最近那个
嗯
又登月了
不是登月
就是毁绕着地球
快快登月
它可能会
毁绕三次就上水了
对对
到2028年或者2022几年
对吧
对
然后我们这个
我就差不多
好
你还有什么想
啊
没有
我很高兴
我们期待下一次我们再聊
好
我们就很随便的
random的
对
我们再聊天
我觉得比较有趣
好吧
那谢谢大家收听这一期
拜拜